let's do the standard New Line logo but
since it's vampires let's make it red
instead of blue get it trained medical
professional slams a pregnant woman's
head on the table
hey childbirth isn't remotely
frightening enough as it is let's cut it
like a horror film and have random
background characters talk about her
being bitten you know to help comfort
the viewer zip code 900 and 3-1 is in
Los Angeles but the state is listed as
Florida giant ask bloody baby doll makes
me nostalgic for the Twilight baby grand
theft baby by making the movie style car
the same font and size as its
immediately preceding lead actor credits
it's possible some of the original
viewing audience suspected blade was
just another actor in this film and
maybe he is sped up time lapse opening
credits footage is both a waste of time
and a metaphor for Humanity's rat race
guy clearly sees a body in a bag and
still follows her deeper into the
slaughterhouse
ladies and gentlemen Traci Lords honest
film career in three seconds I just had
a seizure thanks for that this guy took
dance lessons from Elaine Benes
toe the sprinklers up to blood instead
of water in this illegal temporary Club
where is the blood reservoir that is
tapping into all so this would be like
if a normal night club decided his free
beer all over everyone which would be
very sticky and most of the night called
occupants would rather just drink the
beer normally besides being kind of
gross this seems incredibly wasteful is
this guy the only mortal they brought to
the vampire ball to eat most of the
other vampires here are probably going
to be super pissed that they didn't get
to have any human blood because there's
no way he could feed all of them this
would be like if it was my turn to bring
doughnuts on donut day and I only
brought one doughnut I'd probably have
fired everyone in this joint coordinates
the stoppage of the blood play upon
blades arrival also blade was somehow
able to 100% sneak into this spot at
this moment with no one seeing it which
is goddamn impossible but whatever there
were hundreds of them standing there
right is the movie really trying to tell
me they couldn't all take him on and
instantly succeed but they take him on
one by one storm troopers eat your heart
out we found a group with even prettier
aim than you vampires
this bull time chomping
okay then just blow him up like all the
other vampires who just disintegrated
this is very much on you at this point
blade blade is able to maintain a normal
level of back flexibility even though
his scabbard is built into his jacket
and runs down his back this is the
windiest alley in the history of
cinematic alleys Jesus what are the odds
a character about to be drawn into this
vampire story as a hematologist like
lottery winning odds right
can you sense your right the red blood
cells on that monitor don't make any
sense that is definitely not what your
microscopes should see unless you're
watching a very boring episode of Magic
School Bus
nicely ever have second thoughts about
us guy demonstrates with the timing of
this question why any sensible girl
would break up with it but the reality
is populated by vampires as this movie
will suggest it's a wonder that never
happened before or honestly also this
super charred burn victim now appears to
be cosplaying as a burn victim given his
freedom of movement and the silliness of
his appearance he was played to save the
day because of course he's constantly
monitoring the communications of
seventh-floor hospital employees and the
guy wrapped in hefty bags was never
heard from again
despite leaving tons of victims behind
at crime scenes prior to this blade
decides to get invested in this one
which turns out to be a really good idea
later but whatever bleh just had a
flashback of his mother that he
definitely couldn't remember because he
was just born did play put those pillows
there or did he just luck the fuck out
I think these cops might be even worse
shots than the vampires earlier why even
have guns in your movie she's been
bitten should have killed it it Abraham
would be excellent at cinema since we
can't play this song but Marvel paid
money to play one and a half seconds of
bad moon rising Deacon Frost I'm going
to have a prominent bruise if this movie
keeps beating me over the head with
character names like this are they sure
they don't want to change Karen's name
to doctor pretty brave smart brain I
think my favorite thing about this
vampire movie is the undead UN meeting
where they argue about which kind of
vampire is more important I was born
that's racist
it's vampire racist waking up in a room
like this would probably make me scream
the words please don't kill me look
she's merely confused and surprised ah
the principles of detection tell me
someone was sitting here recently
listening to music and smoking the
hookah not only do they still have
blades mom's driver's license but it is
casually out on this table for caring
too fine Kenan triggers the hand
exploding mechanism and blades sword
without hurting herself serious lady
just happens to bring home a Rando who
is not only a blood scientist but one
who's on to something what are the odds
my name's Abraham were slur that is a
terrible name like the best of the Bible
and old American paintings gas wasting
is waste and many like the cigarette so
when
supposed to go you've been exposed to
them one whale another somebody's gonna
take you out all the more reason for you
to answer her fucking question here
vampire mace if there's one thing people
fear about vampires it's their raw
computational power these are restricted
to the members of the House of Erebus if
I'm being honest I only understood like
50% of what that guy just said what what
is even going on right now lay drops off
this vampire victim girl he helped save
in the heart of danger town why did you
even save her ass eh so blade drops her
off she enters building and immediately
draws vampire assassin followers how
much displayed suck at his job also is
she's supposed to be going he drops her
off and she goes up the elevator at the
first building she finds and then starts
walking fast what's going on this chick
has one lamp turned on and at least four
other lamps in this shot that are turned
off my point is she's rivaling bellow
from Twilight with all these lamps
police officer I didn't mean to scare
you the front door was open this guy
followed the police protocol if the
front doors open the officer is required
to sneak up on the occupant of the home
dead instead of just taking her by
surprise and shooting her this guy has
to insult her before trying to kill her
this guy is holding a gun but because he
got vampire maced he forgets all about
it no one is even remotely suspicious of
the guy and the leather trench coat
beating the shit out of a cop in broad
daylight time lapse to show passage of
time cliche this movie does a lot of
that using the same stock tire screech
sound twice within ten seconds so
forgive what you've seen in the movies
does that include this movie I'd love to
forget what I've seen in this movie you
know how to use one of these No
h-how'd am xolali ruby designs that she
doesn't know how to use a gun but she
immediately learns how instead of just
having her already know how to use a gun
put a head on a heart anything else
yo ass even though blade has killed
countless vampires during the course of
this movie by hitting them anywhere in
their midsection not only was this
computer able to translate the ancient
text but it was also able to generate
this 3d model because this version of
rosetta stone has a blueprint generator
just in case it decides a series of
hieroglyphs this actually plans for a
structure of some kind but appreciate
the help random vampire chick but I've
got this and you were stupid enough to
take it vampire the hut parts equal
humor right not sure if movie is just
throwing in jumpy cuts of blades next
adversary aware if I'm having a stroke
instead of luring blade out of the
vampire Bible room they decide to bring
the fight there so they can destroy
these priceless artifacts get you is
that a bad time whistling ex machina
Abraham survives this though at this
point we shouldn't be surprised
blades mother was attacked by a vampire
while she was pregnant any of the
vampire somehow it didn't just kill and
eat the fetus instead a super vamp was
born he'd undergone certain genetic
changes oh I thought the serum was
supposed to suppress that his body
started to reject it x position x
position x position
yes x position x position x cigarettes
and whiskey the prop masters best friend
for letting the audience know a
character doesn't give a wife two
daughters the sky rattles off his dead
relatives like they're the names of
books he read in school there's
something happening in the vampire ranks
there's something big
well it tells me a lot how big is it
told me what happened
snitches get stitches though he told me
what you are you don't know anything
about me except for all that stuff that
Abraham just told her basically your
entire backstory you are lucky you got
what you deserve discount I inspired
like 50 percent of Lady Gaga's look
neither frost nor any of his vampire
friends are affected by the Sun rising
quite like the guy they brought out here
to kill yeah yeah sunscreen sunscreen
also this guy is already burning even
though the Sun hasn't risen yet why the
hell is no one else burning up right now
I see that they have on their motorcycle
getup but their faces are still exposed
to the Sun until they put down these
visors and don't tell me it's because
they put on this sunscreen because I
call bolt on that being effective and
Dragonetti was definitely burning
through his clothes earlier so they
should all be reenacting the Ark of the
Covenant right now it's
something about the blood guide the
spirits of the twelve this is the most
Buffy the Vampire Slayer wrist of any
modern vampire sudden magic blood text I
can read that
give it here casual stealing also Karen
stole an entire lab from the hospital
presumably by herself take a step back
the reactions energetic why not just say
don't put your eyes on that cuz it's
about to explode y'all a vampire who
picked this girl has the widest apart
fucking vampire incisors in the history
of teeth that's almost like two inches
son boobie continues to expect me to
believe that Frost is completely
impervious to the sun's UV rays because
he's wearing sunblock how do these
assholes standing here like this without
someone calling 9-1-1 about the creeper
and the abducted asian girl Jesus even
blade is a goddamn storm trooper with
the gun in his hands
blade rescues girl who should not have
been in danger anyway since this truck
should have fucking slammed on the
brakes ages ago
nice place how did you find it though
Sergio Garcia frost took her fine but
why did he leave you even a little bit
alive there's some kind of vampire guy
he's trying man it's bad enough you
aren't dead but you're also an
exposition fairy Jesus just die already
blade pulls the gauze off the wounds for
a moment but it has very little blood on
it almost as though these aren't gushing
wounds but actually an eerily dry makeup
jobs why is blade basically petting
whistlers wounds with dirty gauze plate
just knocked off all six special bullets
he's melted himself now he's gonna have
to pick them up one by one in case you
were clueless about the metaphor blade
will now literally chop a plant off at
the root seemed a bit tense she actually
looks calm is but whatever few were once
human I like how the director kept
cutting to this blonde chick on the
couch during the scene since I have no
idea who she is or why her reaction
should matter like gods come as
hurricane an act of God he's referring
to the blood God as an act of God even
though the blood God's name calls him a
God himself which would seem to negate
thee God's involvement in these
proceedings movie saves a few bucks by
lifting the stupidness from the computer
renders in the movie disclosure
blade is stupid enough to let his guard
down after the dead mothers trick so as
to be easily tased here in dead mother's
man also tasers work on the undead who
new name is sure probably true but I'm
still more concerned with why they put
you two together in captivity and
allowed you to keep your body armor
here try to understand Eric I forgot
this is blades mother for a second
there's some weird Freudian going on
right now in Hollywood they call this
The Lost Boys effect and here it's
combined with the Bruce Almighty moon
blade this chick saves blade through
pure guesswork you have to bite me and
turn me in order to save the world
cliche ripped off from every vampire
movie ever I'm not entirely sure he is
still just sucking her blood
ladies and gentlemen special effects
[Music]
late movie thinks it can reap good will
for the finale by playing some of that
matrix action music that doesn't exist
yet hey Karen maybe if you aim for one
of the columns you might hit the girl
earlier Whistler said the garlic would
cause anaphylactic shock I had no idea
anaphylactic shock makes your head
explode so basically this is the vampire
version of bloodsport right didn't you
just bite and turn her she's not a king
daywalker right there does anyone you
might turn into you know what could I
officially don't care you and the undead
horse he rode in on movie busy in Moscow
right now hunting vampires did he run
out of vampires in the u.s. to hunt I
guess we won't know until Blade 2 Bart
Simpson story
King Richard Chamberlain is Principal
Skinner Joe Mantegna is Fat Tony Dean
Seymour is the woman he loved and TVs
Doogie Howser deal Patrick Harris as
Bart Simpson ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
sins and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
who are you people what do you mean you
think you were sloppy you got what you
deserve I'm getting what I deserve I'm
reaping what I saw well the number field
sieve is the best method currently known
there exists an intriguing possibility
for a far more elegant